l'union européenne attend des avancées
dans le dossier navalni à la suite du
verdict qui envoyait l'opposant russe en
prison pour un peu plus de deux ans et
demi de nombreux responsables
occidentaux ont demandé à l'unisson sa
libération immédiate
josep borrell qui a maintenu son
déplacement à moscou malgré les
réticences de certains états membres a
lui même admis je cite qu'il
n'obtiendrait sans doute pas sa
libération
en effet le responsable européen est
attendu de pied ferme au ministère russe
des affaires étrangères où l'on estime
qu'un procès injuste est intentée contre
la russie on a l'impression que les
responsables occidentaux refusent tout
simplement de voir ce qui se passe dans
leur pays ce qui se passe ces jours même
dans l'union européenne ce qui se passe
c'est moi même aux états unis
il détourne délibérément l'attention de
l'opinion publique mondiale de la
situation dans leur pays
se focalisant sur leur vision de la
situation en russie
demain lors des discussions entre
sergueï lavrov et josep borrell haut
représentant de l'union européenne pour
les affaires étrangères
nous aborderons l'ensemble des questions
concernant les déclarations
inacceptables les pseudos évaluation la
distorsion des faits du côté du kremlin
on espère cependant que cette rencontre
sera constructive
malgré les tensions les différences de
points de vue sur un très grand nombre
de dossiers nous attachons une grande
importance à la prochaine visite de
joseph bourrel
vous savez tous récemment faisant le
point sur les relations entre moscou et
bruxelles
le président poutine a déploré qu elles
soient en fait je les hais ce n'est pas
la russie qui est à l'origine de ce gel
bien évidemment nous souhaitons
débloquer notre dialogue tous azimuts
entre moscou et bruxelles notamment pour
discuter ouvertement et franchement de
l'ensemble des divergences qui sont
assez nombreuses
la rencontre entre sergueï lavrov et
josep borrell sera en tout cas scrutée
de près par les européens qui font
planer la menace de sanctions si leurs
exigences ne trouve pas un écho
favorable du côté des autorités russes